[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
AMANDA PHINGBODHIPAKKIYA:
Thanks so much, [? Theresa. ?]
Hello, everyone.
It's so wonderful to be here.
Thank you for having me.
I'm going to start
off with a story.
And it begins, as all good
stories, do on Amtrak.
So it was the end of 2016, and
I was traveling from Boston
to New York.
I just spent Christmas
with my partner's family,
and we were all still just
processing the results
of the November election.
One of my good
friends told me that I
should pick a cause that
I care deeply about,
and support it in a
way that only I could.
So I thought back to one of
my childhood heroes, Rita
Levi-Montalcini, who
discovered nerve growth
factor in the 1940s.
Her initial discovery wasn't
at the University of Turin,
but actually in a
makeshift laboratory
she'd set up in her
bedroom after Mussolini
had barred Jewish people from
working in academic settings.
I knew there were
other women like her
who had made significant
improvements to their fields.
But I was drawing a blank.
The only other name
that came to mind
was a legendary
scientist, Marie Curie.
So I started Beyond Curie,
a series of illustrations
and stories that celebrates the
rich history of women kicking
ass in science, technology,
engineering, and mathematics--
women like Maryam Mirzakhani
and Mary Golda Ross.
I started it so that
young women everywhere
could stop wondering if
they had the potential
to make an impact in STEM,
and instead start asking,
why should we stop now?
The project was funded by a
Kickstarter campaign, which
attracted hundreds of backers--
parents, teachers,
engineers, and scientists--
who wanted the
women in their lives
to be inspired by
that same legacy.
In partnership with the
March for Science organizers.
I released a special
series of posters
that anyone could download and
print for a rally or protest.
And a couple of months later, I
headed down to Washington, DC,
along with thousands
of others, and we stood
huddled under our umbrellas
on that wet, dreary day,
taking to the streets
of the nation's capital
to stand up for science.
And that's when I saw
her, a woman carrying
a huge bedazzled Beyond Curie
poster of Rosalind Franklin,
the scientist who had
made crucial contributions
to the understanding of
DNA's double helix structure.
It was the same
poster that I had
brought with me to the march.
She told me that she
was getting her PhD
and had flown into
DC from South Dakota.
For her, the poster
was a powerful reminder
that women belong in the
lab just as much as men do.
Now, as I've continued
to work on Beyond Curie,
I've gone deeper and
deeper into the lives
of these incredible women and
their groundbreaking work.
How were they able to push
through when others weren't?
What methods did they
use to gain new insights
and get their work recognized
in a male-dominated field?
And how can these
lessons be transferred
outside of the realm of deep
scientific and engineering
research and into the
lives of the rest of us?
Today, I want to share with
you the stories of four
of these women featured in
the Beyond Curie series--
exploring how their work
unfolded, and a little bit more
about their personalities.
This first lesson is about
what to do when you have
a truly groundbreaking idea.
We live in an era
where innovators
have brought brilliant
and sometimes devastating
inventions and breakthroughs
into the world,
but not all ideas
are immediately
ready for the limelight.
So what do you do?
If you bury it,
are you giving up?
No one wants to be a quitter.
But if you push for it as
a lone voice in the wild,
you might just get
cast out and ignored,
which means your work never
gets the impact it deserves.
This is a story of
staying in the game.
Barbara McClintock
was born in 1902.
She spent most of her
childhood in Brooklyn,
and her parents early on noted
her solitary and independent
streak, discarding the
name Eleanor, the name they
had initially intended
on giving her as being
too delicate and feminine.
She found her love for
science in high school,
and was accepted later
into Cornell's College
of Agriculture, where she
earned a bachelors and then
a PhD in botany,
focusing on maize.
That's the grain with
the multicolored kernels,
also known as Indian corn.
So after postdocs at Caltech
and the University of Missouri,
where she made
crucial contributions
to the understanding of
genetic replication in maize,
she accepted a faculty position
at Cold Springs Harbor in 1942.
And it was there at this
leading biomedical facility
in upstate New York that
she made her groundbreaking
discoveries in genetics.
Now, it all started
with a simple question.
Why does maize have
differently colored kernels?
Some of them are yellow.
Some of them are purple.
Sometimes there's this
weird mosaic pattern.
Why is that?
The scientific
consensus at the time
was that genetic
replication in genes
were ordered in a fixed pattern.
So that meant that
theoretically, from ear to ear,
maize should have
similar coloring.
So Barbara developed some of
these amazing X-ray techniques
to induce mutations in cells.
And she noticed that
different segments of DNA
would jump around the
chromosomes when this happened.
She also noticed that
other segments of DNA
would turn genes on and off.
Her findings led to a theory
about the uneven coloring
in maize kernels.
So if a piece of DNA was
dropped into a segment that
coded for purple pigment, it
might disrupt that pigmentation
and cause a mosaic kernel.
If it was dropped into a segment
that turned genes on and off,
it might result in a
non-pigmented yellow kernel.
McClintock was a highly
respected scientist,
and her peers in botany
appreciated the work
that she was doing.
But other scientists, they
thought she was crazy.
They responded with
puzzlement and even hostility,
as she described it.
She gave a big talk in
1951 summarizing a paper
that she had written
for a major symposium.
The room goes dead silent.
Talk about a tough crowd.
But it didn't
bother her too much.
She said, it didn't
bother me that much,
because when you
know you're right,
you know that sooner or later,
it will come out in the wash.
So she continues to
publish her work on maize.
But after years, and years,
and years of resistance,
she starts moving
on to other areas.
She does seminal work on
evolutionary pathways of maize,
and she travels to Central and
South America to do this work.
At the same time, the field
of genetics moves forward.
Other scientists start to see
this jumping gene phenomenon
in bacteria and yeast.
Also advances in
technology improve.
So now they're
able to understand
exactly what's happening.
They realize that McClintock's
weird corn breeding
research is actually
fundamental to genetics,
and it's really a foundation
for all of these other fields,
and has implications for
every biomedical field.
She's the first person to
win the MacArthur Genius
grant, the first woman
to receive the National
Medal of Science, and
finally, after over 30 years,
she's given the Nobel Prize
in physiology and medicine.
She is the first American
woman to win an unshared Nobel
Prize in any category.
She also gets a building
named after her at Cold Spring
Harbor, which is cool too.
So McClintock isn't the only
one who had to wait years
to get her work recognized.
In 2017, the MeToo movement
brought down Harvey Weinstein,
and reverberated across the
country and around the world,
irreversibly changing
the conversation
around sexual harassment.
But its origins began
more than a decade earlier
with the work of social
activist and community
organizer, Tarana Burke.
Born in the Bronx to a
low-income household,
she experienced sexual violence
as a girl and young woman.
In 2003, she started a
nonprofit called Just
Be that developed programming
for young black girls and teens
to succeed socially
and professionally.
She first used the phrase
"me too" on Myspace
as part of the campaign
to promote empowerment
through empathy among
survivors of sexual abuse.
This campaign became
so important to her
that in 2008, she renamed
her nonprofit Me Too.
She continued this
community work traveling
to Brooklyn and Selma.
And then on October 15th, 2017,
Alyssa Milano posted on Twitter
about #MeToo for the
first time, and it
received 24,000 retweets,
and set off a tidal wave
that continues to this day.
Later on, Milano
followed up that tweet,
crediting Burke
with her earlier use
of the phrase and her
longstanding efforts
to support survivors
of sexual abuse.
Tarana Burke went on to be named
one of Time Magazine's silence
breakers, which Time Magazine
named 2017 person of the year.
And she was this year's
commencement speaker
at U Penn's School of
Social Policy and Practice.
McClintock's and Burke's
stories, they share parallels,
including their initial
rise in the field.
McClintock's early maize work
was considered first rate,
and Burke had started
her community activism
as a young girl, and continued
it wherever she went.
They also both had
a breakthrough idea.
For McClintock, it was
that genetic regulation
could be controlled.
For Burke, it was
that one of the ways
to help survivors
heal and communicate
the awful prevalence
of sexual abuse
is to share one's own story.
And for both of
them, it took years
of working on other things,
putting their initial idea
aside, and waiting until
the world was ready for them
to get the recognition
they deserved.
It takes some time for
ideas to permeate the world.
And yeah, it probably
was much harder for them
because they were women.
But by making their mark
and staying in the game,
their fields were able to
recognize the importance
of their contributions.
The next lesson
that I think we can
learn from leading
scientists is that the world
needs more champions.
Women are often
given the advice,
go find a mentor, someone who's
had some more years on you
in the field and can
offer advice or approaches
to your work.
But having a mentor
isn't enough.
Women and ambitious people of
every stripe need champions.
And the surest way to understand
the difference between a mentor
and a champion is to look at
Elizabeth Blackburn and Carol
Greider.
So in the late 1970s
and early '80s,
the field of molecular biology
was brimming with excitement.
There were lots of advances
being made, including
the discovery of telomeres,
which are repeating segments
at the ends of chromosomes
that essentially protect
them and keep them from
injecting bad or erroneous DNA
during replication.
So Elizabeth Blackburn
was a postdoc at the time.
She was doing early
work on telomeres,
actually studying
pond scum, because it
was cheap and readily
available, and
because cellular replication
is generally highly conserved,
which means it's the same
in pond scum, and mammals,
and plants, and even humans.
So she sets up her
lab at UC Berkeley,
and in 1983, she recruits a
young University of San Diego
biology major,
named Carol Greider.
So Greider had done
great in undergrad.
She was already an accomplished
researcher in her own right,
and knew her way around the lab.
But she suffered from
dyslexia, which meant
she didn't really test well.
So when it came time to
interview for her PhD program,
she only got offers at
two places to interview,
and one of them was UC Berkeley.
After meeting with the team,
she said, you know what?
This seems like a great place
to do research and a great group
of people to work with.
She was all in.
She worked 12-hour
days in the lab,
learned all different kinds
of techniques on the fly,
and engaged in a lot of
intense intellectual discussion
with Blackburn.
The duo hypothesized that
there was some kind of enzyme,
a protein probably,
that would regulate
this cellular replication
and control telomeres.
Finally, after many, many
tests, around Christmas time,
Carol comes rushing in with the
results of an experiment that
show an enzyme that
could potentially
be the one that they
had hypothesized.
Blackburn remembers this exact
moment and thinking, wow,
this is something big.
So eventually, Carol moves on.
She gets her PhD, goes on to
teach at Cold Springs Harbor,
and then gets a faculty
position at Johns Hopkins,
where she still does
research and teaches today.
Then in 2009, she, Blackburn,
and a third scientist
who had worked on the
early work of telomeres
won the Nobel Prize in
Physiology and Medicine.
Blackburn wasn't a
mentor for Greider.
She was her champion.
She pushed Greider.
She made sure that they
connected on a daily basis.
This is uncommon
in grad programs.
Usually principal
investigators touch base
with their graduate
students maybe once a month.
Blackburn also made sure
that Carol got credit
for the discovery that
she made, even though she
was only one year
out of undergrad
and a very young researcher--
something that
Jocelyn Bell Burnell
never got from her
principal investigator.
Jocelyn discovered
the first pulsars,
but instead of sharing credit,
her principal investigator
took the credit.
So the lesson is to find
champions and be a champion
for others when you can.
But easier said
than done, right?
Wouldn't we all love to have
a brilliant, influential,
encouraging leader who
is helping us do highly
visible and impactful work?
Of course.
But how does this actually
happen in practice?
One of the best examples is
from the Obama administration.
A couple of years ago,
"The Washington Post"
did a piece on Obama's first
term when 2/3 of his aides
were men.
So women had to elbow their
way to get into meetings.
And when they were there, they
were talked over and ignored.
So the women got
together and developed
something called
amplification, where
when a woman made a key
point, other women would
repeat it, and then
give that woman credit.
This had the dual
impact of making sure
that their ideas and
their voices were heard,
but also it made sure that
the men couldn't take credit
for their ideas.
And it worked.
We saw Obama calling
more and more directly
on the women in those meetings.
Now my last story comes
from Asia, which is fitting,
because I owe the opportunity
to give this talk to the Asian
Google network.
Youyou Tu is a Chinese
pharmaceutical chemist
who led a team that
developed a breakthrough
cure for tropical malaria,
for which she won the Nobel
Prize in 2015.
Youyou Tu grew up in Ningbo,
which is about 120 miles south
of Shanghai.
And as a young child, she
developed a serious case
of tuberculosis, which
actually inspired her
to go into medical research.
Now, she studied at
the Beijing University
School of Pharmacology,
and graduated in 1955.
A couple of years later in 1960,
the North Vietnamese leader,
Ho Chi Minh, appealed
to his friend and ally,
the Chinese premier, for help.
North Vietnamese
soldiers were dropping
like flies from
tropical malaria,
and the current cure, chloro
quinine, was ineffective.
It just so happened
that in Southern China,
lots of citizens were
dying from malaria as well.
So the Chinese premier
asked Mao Zedong
to set up a secret
government program called
Project 523 to discover a cure.
It's not really that
original of a name,
since it's after the date of
its founding, May 23, 1967.
Regardless, they
recruited 500 scientists
from all over the
country, different labs,
and institutions, to participate
in the fight against malaria.
Youyou Tu joins in 1969.
She actually had to put her
young daughter in a nursery
as she traveled
to Southern China
to investigate
what was going on.
So around the world,
other scientists
are getting involved.
They've tested over 240,000
different compounds for a cure,
to no avail.
So Youyou Tu decides to
retread some old ground
and go back and look at
traditional Chinese medicine.
She travels around
the country, talking
to different Chinese
medicine practitioners,
compiling all of
her notes and all
of this research
in a big notebook.
By early 1971, she
and her team had
tested over 2,000 recipes
from Chinese medicine,
had extracted about 380 herbal
extracts from 200 herbs,
and tested it on mice.
Then they found
out that there was
one compound from the sweet
wormwood plant that seemed
like it might be a contender.
This compound was known to
help with intermittent fevers,
was a characteristic
of malaria, and also it
proved to inhibit
parasite growth.
So after testing it
on mice, Youyou Tu
steps forward as the very
first human test subject.
She actually tested it on
herself, which is incredible.
Fortunately, it's
safe for humans.
It works.
Patient trials continue,
which prove highly successful.
But no one in the world knows
about this research because
of the Cultural Revolution and
because this is a highly secret
military project.
But once these international
relations reopen,
Youyou Tu is asked to present
the findings of Project 523
to the World Health
Organization.
After that, more
folks start to use
artemisinin, which is what they
ended up calling this compound.
And it's one of the frontline
tools against malaria.
So between 2000 and 2012, the
global incidence of malaria
drops 25%, and the global
mortality rate for malaria
drops 42%.
In a recent estimate, it's
said that her discovery
of artemisinin has saved
hundreds of millions of lives.
Pretty incredible, right?
So another woman who's not so
afraid to retread old ground
to discover new insights
is former GE vice chair,
Beth Comstock.
Now, Comstock started
her career at NBC News
as a journalist
in Washington, DC.
A couple of years later,
she gets the opportunity
to travel to New York for
new job opportunities.
Despite having a small child
and being a single parent,
she takes the leap.
And this move to the
big city pays off.
She gets opportunities
at CNN and then at CBS,
running East Coast PR
for the classiest network
in the country.
Then in 1993, she gets a
call to return back to NBC.
They have an
opening for the vice
president of media relations.
But the problem is that
recently, NBC just got outed
for running a fake news story.
Morale was in the toilet.
Resistance to her taking this
job, even considering it,
started immediately
after she got the call.
But she knew that
in her gut, this
was the job for her to take.
Something was calling
Comstock back to NBC.
And she ended up following
her gut and being correct.
They gave her a lot of latitude.
She was able to experiment
and try new things.
And two years later,
she launched MSNBC
with the help of Jack
[? Welch ?] and Bill Gates.
And it's now the second most
watched channel on cable news.
Learning to retread old
ground to find new insights--
it's a lesson that I used myself
in developing Beyond Curie.
I would never have known
that my fourth grade book
report on Rita
Levi-Montalcini would
be the spark for a
project that would
have such a global response,
lead to a main stage TED Talk,
and also lead to a whole
highway tunnel dedicated
to women in STEM.
In fact, I didn't
even think I'd still
be working on Beyond Curie.
But I'm glad that I am.
Beyond Curie is about
discovering our heroes,
because when we're able
to connect with greatness,
we come to see that it is
not some distant, unreachable
place, but a long
body of work forged
through perseverance,
love, and courage,
because when we
truly know our past,
we can reclaim our present.
And when we hold the
present in our hands,
the future is ours to shape.
Thanks so much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
I guess we can open
up to questions.
AUDIENCE: I noticed you
made multiple references
to Cold Springs Harbor.
Was that a coincidence, or was
there some reason for that?
AMANDA PHINGBODHIPAKKIYA:
Well, it's
a leading biomedical
institution,
so a lot of people who have won
the Nobel Prize did work there.
But I guess in this talk,
purely by coincidence.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk
more about the format
of this project, Beyond Curie,
and how can girls and women
access it, and connect
to these messages
that you're trying to convey?
AMANDA PHINGBODHIPAKKIYA:
Absolutely.
So it lives online
at beyondcurie.com.
We do a lot of exhibits
around the country
and around the world that
shows these portraits,
gives a small little description
of what these scientists
and technologists have
contributed to the world,
and also there's an AR app in
the Apple and Android store.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AMANDA PHINGBODHIPAKKIYA: Sure.
Oh, there's also a
Kickstarter that we're
running right now
that's holiday cards,
in case you're
interested in sharing
these women for the holidays.
AUDIENCE: Have you considered
working with schools,
or are you working with
schools around the country,
to encourage girls be made aware
of, and girls and boys, really?
AMANDA PHINGBODHIPAKKIYA:
That's a great idea.
We are working with
several schools.
It's kind of come
about organically.
We field a lot of
inbound from schools,
and we donate a lot of
sets of these posters
and little wall
decals for schools.
But if you have
other suggestions,
I'm definitely open.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AMANDA PHINGBODHIPAKKIYA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Can you share a little
more about your own journey
from being a
neuroscientist to coming up
with these works of art, and
how that took off, and turned
into Beyond Curie as an
organization and everything?
AMANDA PHINGBODHIPAKKIYA: Sure.
So I realized that I was better
at communicating research
and communicating science than
actually doing the science,
and I could make
more impact there.
So I got my MFA at
Pratt, and after that, I
bounced around different art
director and creative director
positions.
And then I got the
opportunity to do something
called the TED Residency, which
is an incubator program where
you have some sort of idea worth
spreading that you apply with.
Mine was that design can
shine a light on breakthroughs
happening in science.
And I actually incubated another
project, not Beyond Curie,
there.
It's a program that pairs
scientists and designers
to cocreate works of art and
design that translate research.
And we put out pop-up exhibits
all over the country and work
with different institutions.
Beyond Curie started
because I was
trying to find a
way to give back
after the election and support
causes that I believed in.
And supporting women in
STEM is one of the ones
that I believe in a lot.
So I started it as a
little digital project
that I wanted to put online.
I thought, you know what?
There are so many women that
people don't know about.
Never heard their names before.
They've probably heard
of their discoveries,
but never knew that
women made them.
So why don't we create a
format that's colorful,
that's visually appealing so
that people's attentions are
grabbed, and then we
can roll the stories
into this experience?
I did not expect for
it to be picked up
by "Fast Company" and a bunch
of other different media
networks, which is kind of how
it grew to a global phenomenon.
And I've just been continuing
to work on it, adding scientists
to it.
And we try very hard to go
into different countries
and work with
different institutions
to figure out
what's a way that we
can bring Beyond Curie there.
[LAUGHS] Thanks so
much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]